winner winner chicken dinner
Jordan Smith ladies gentlemen Adam how
do you feel about beating Blake again I
feel so good
oh man I'm gonna enjoy this night on a
completely selfish level Jordan just
want you to know it's really quite
beautiful because Jordan is to win the
voice and I get to tear Blake apart for
the next God six months bragging about
my win and his drought of victory it's
gonna be great
I'm trying I'm gonna think of new and
exciting ways to make them feel terrible
it's gonna be really fun guys
so thank you the answer is psyched
you're welcome where's they my man the
22 year old got candid talking about his
big winning moment honestly there there
are so many times where I just did not
even expect to be in this position and
I'm still kind of blown away by that and
and this is so surreal just because I
never expected to even be this far but
I'm so honored to be I'm so proud to be
sitting here out of all these people
they're so great and and I think that
this is one of this is just so unreal
it's just one of the craziest moments
that I've experienced